this video is sponsored by war thunder a
realistic free to play military vehicle
combat game it's available on pc ps5
xbox series x and previous generations
of consoles as well no need to purchase
anything just download and play in this
game there are more than 2 000
historically accurate tanks helicopters
ships and other vehicles spanning the
entire 20th century they're all
carefully built and incredibly detailed
operating in a realistic physics engine
it's an immersive gaming experience with
real historical campaigns even the sound
is incredible and you can just jump in
for a quick arcade game which is great
if you're pressed for time or you're
just looking for something casual i
personally prefer just to jump in and
give something a play i'm pretty busy
dude don't have time to dedicate to
learning all the complexities i just
want a bit of fun but if you're a bit
more hardcore you could play realistic
go for some challenging tactical stuff
right now you can join war thunder and
its 50 million worldwide players on the
battlefield for free using the link
below and for those of you that do jump
into the game using my link war thunder
is giving you a free premium tank
aircraft or ship plus three days of
premium play for free it's a great deal
and thanks to war thunder of sponsoring
and now today's video
new crime reporter leo catcher said that
arnold rothstein transformed organized
crime from a thuggish activity practiced
by hoodlums into a big business run like
a corporation with himself at the top he
gathered the loose single strands of
crime and wove them into a tapestry he
took the various elements that were
needed to change crime from petty
larceny into big business and fused them
the end result was a machine that runs
smoothly today a bit overdramatic
perhaps but it does well to illustrate
the impact that arnold rothstein had on
crime in america all of the notorious
mobsters that you've heard of who have
already been featured here on
biographics lucky luciano melansky frank
costello they all learned their business
from the man known as the brain mr big
and the big bankroll arnold rothstein
[Music]
arnold rothstein was born on january the
17th 1882 in new york city he was the
second son of abraham and esther
rothstein he was part of a wealthy and
influential ashkenazi jewish family and
he grew up in luxury in a swanky home in
manhattan abraham rothstein also known
as abe the just in his local community
was a man who cherished philanthropy
piety and honesty and also served as
chairman on the board of the best israel
hospital his oldest son harry studied to
become a rabbi arnold on the other hand
didn't really follow in their footsteps
in fact the only thing he seemed to
inherit from his father was his business
acumen from a young age arnold resented
his older brother harry since he felt
that he received most of the care and
attention from their parents according
to an interview with a psychologist the
most emotional moment in rostein's
childhood occurred when he was six years
old and his father found him hiding and
sobbing uncontrollably in a closet
screaming that everybody hated him and
loved harry his jealousy only grew as
the years passed especially when harry
announced that he wanted to enter
rabbinical school to the great delight
of his father gambling was another
driving wedge between young arnold and
his father as you might imagine abe
rothstein disapproved of gambling
whereas arnold never found a pair of
dice that he didn't like as soon as he
won his first part arnold knew that it
didn't get any better than that nothing
and nobody could persuade him to stop
school didn't mean much for arnold
either the only subject where he showed
any interest was arithmetic he was great
with numbers but that only was because
he saw that they could be used to make
him become a better gambler he got held
back a few times and by the time he
turned 16 he dropped out of school
completely rothstein then took a few
jobs as a traveling salesman he was good
at it and enjoyed the work but it simply
didn't make enough cash to keep his
interest no if rothstein was going to
maintain the comfortable lifestyle that
he grew accustomed to he would need to
find more lucrative business
opportunities a strange moment in his
life occurred when rothstein was around
18 years old still a traveling salesman
at that point he was in eerie
pennsylvania when he received a message
from home his older brother harry the
sibling that he had resented his whole
life had died of pneumonia this was a
turning point in rothstein's life for a
while harry's death persuaded him to try
one last time to mend the relationship
that he had with his father he moved
back home stayed away from his usual
gambling haunts and even went to
synagogue with abe it was a nice gesture
but it didn't last long eventually he
had another row with his father and he
left the family home again this time
determined to strike out on his own from
that moment on arnold rothstein fully
embarked on his life of crime and he
never looked back
[Applause]
for the next few years of rothstein's
life the pool halls bookies and gambling
denzel new york became his new home away
from home uh hammerstein's victoria
theater and the broadway central hotel
were favorite hangouts of his and
rothstein already started to acquaint
himself with some of the locals of
dubious reputation who frequented such
dens of iniquity soon enough he had
saved up enough money to become a loan
shark nothing major just fifty dollars
here and a hundred dollars there but
rostein was good at making himself
appear like a bigger deal than he
actually was he developed a habit of
always carrying around a lot of dollar
bills thick enough to choke a pelican he
would flash it every time he got the
opportunity to make it seem like that
was just some walking around money to
him when in fact it was most of the cash
that he had in the world rostein also
showed himself eager to spend it more
than happy to fund other people's
gambling habits as long as they paid it
back with 25 interest and those who
refused to pay well let's just say that
they would receive a nasty visit from
some of arnold's pals rothstein himself
didn't like to get his hands dirty but
he had associates who had no such qualms
sooner or later everybody paid up it was
around this time that rothstein's
profile grew large enough that he
started hanging out with a better class
of criminals the crooked politicians
specifically timothy big tim sullivan
one of the tammany hall bigwigs who
controlled the democratic vote in
several areas of manhattan 20 years
older than rothstein sullivan was
already a force to be reckoned with by
the time the young gambler started
breaking into the new york underworld a
mentorship relationship began evolving
between the two just like the one that
rothstein would later develop with
future mobsters such as lucky luciano
and frank costello sullivan taught
rothstein the importance of building a
network of relations everyone from
janitors to judges had some kind of
value if you used them right people soon
learned that if they had a tip for any
kind of money-making opportunity be it
legal or illegal arnold rothstein was
the one willing to pay top dollar for it
with such insider information he moved
up from small-time pool hall games to
big poker tournaments horse races prize
fights any crooked game in new york you
could bet on arnold rothstein would be
there he once quipped that he would bet
on anything except the weather since it
was the only thing he couldn't control
in 1907 rothstein met and fell in love
with a 19 year old showgirl named
carolyn greene he intended to marry her
and even brought her to meet his parents
although this had the predictable
outcome of an argument between father
and son the devout abraham blew a fuse
when he found out that his son's
half-jewish bride-to-be had been raised
catholic and had no intention of
converting of course his father's
approval was not high on arnold
rothstein's list of priorities
especially since he wasn't exactly
genesis prize material either the couple
stayed together despite a rothsted's
protestations and two years later they
got married in saratoga springs as
rostein's fortune grow it made sense for
him to open his own gambling house which
he did with the help from sullivan who
offered him protection on his new joint
sullivan's assistance did come with a
bothersome catch though as rothstein had
to take on a former building inspector
named william cher as a partner cher was
an anti-semite who distrusted rothstein
so unsurprisingly the two butted heads
quite often until one night when
rothstein took the drunken share into
signing away his side of the partnership
for forty thousand dollars once that
little annoyance was dealt with rostein
got back to what mattered most to him
making money his casino was located
inside two brownstones on west 46th
street near the theater district and as
you entered it became evident that it
wasn't the kind of joint where you would
drop a few nickels and dimes no
rothstein's gambling house was the type
of place where the showgirls were
friendly and the liquor was plentiful
and it was obviously intended to attract
big time spenders with deep pockets and
poor judgment
[Music]
by the time he turned 30 in 1912 arnold
rothstein had become a millionaire he
never stopped gambling of course but he
also expanded his portfolio by dipping
his fingers in a lot of profitable pies
loan sharking smuggling bail bonding
anything that would make money rothstein
didn't have a crew his speciality was
putting the right people in contact with
each other or working on the business
end of a racket his role was that of a
fixer or a go-between but of course he
always collected his cut it was also
around this time that he began acting as
a mentor to some of the up-and-coming
mobsters who worked for him guys like
mayor lansky jack leggs diamond and
lucky luciano all studied under the tree
of rothstein and later expressed their
admiration for his talents lansky said
that rothstein had the most remarkable
brain when it came to business and that
he would have become rich and successful
even if it stayed legitimate meanwhile
lucky revealed that his relationship
with ross dean was more than strictly
business luciano said he taught me how
to dress how to use knives and forks and
things like that at the dinner table
about holding a door open for a girl if
arnold had lived a little longer he
could have made me pretty elegant one of
the things that made rothstein so
valuable as a partner was his connection
to the new york political machine
according to crime writer leah catcher
everyone turned to arnold lawyers fixers
people in trouble sought him out he was
a pipeline to tammany hall if you wanted
a favor from the hall arnold rothstein
could expedite it assure it for you and
so
you paid him 1913 was a pivotal year for
rothstein because two of new york's most
influential and most corrupt political
players were taken out of the game one
was his former mentor big tim sullivan
or the king of the bowery as he liked to
be called who died in september 1913
when his body was almost sliced into by
a speeding train the circumstances under
which he ended up on the train tracks
are still up for debate was it murder
suicide or accident the other bigwig who
bit the dust was police captain charles
becker who was arrested for planning and
ordering the 1912 murder of bookie
herman rosenthal becker was not only
convicted but also executed for the
crime becoming one of the few crooked
cops to face capital punishment this
could have been a big problem for
rothstein as he lost two of his biggest
connections in the same year but
fortunately for him the more things
changed the more they stayed the same
old acquaintances were simply replaced
by new ones and his role remained mostly
the same if anything his criminal empire
continued to grow as rothstein opened
two new casinos in long island and
saratoga and also started getting
involved in the drug trade his setup in
saratoga in particular was said to be
among the swankiest ones in the country
known as the brook it combined a casino
with a restaurant a nightclub and a
cabaret show and it attracted some of
the biggest gamblers in america mobsters
like bugsy siegel and mayor lansky would
emulate his pension for luxury with
their own establishments in the future
but it was rothstein who first thought
to invest in deluxe businesses in order
to attract a higher class of clientele
one of the few times that rothstein got
into trouble with the law happened in
1919 when police conducted a raid on a
gambling den when the detectives started
pounding the door they were met with
gunshots there were only a few minor
injuries and the entire party was
arrested including rothstein and his
bodyguard even though nodey identified
the shooter rothstein was caught trying
to get rid of a revolver so he was the
one indicted on assault charges nothing
ever came of it though a judge dismissed
the charges on the basis of a faulty
raid because the officers didn't
identify themselves as police and a
faulty indictment because no evidence
was submitted to directly implicate
rothstein as the shooter whether the
ruling was legitimate or rothstein
simply bribed his way out the end result
was the same arnold was a free man and
he could get back to business and his
plans grew even more ambitious
[Music]
with the world of crime being inherently
secretive even to its own members it is
unsurprising that it has given rise to
numerous myths rumors and legends jimmy
hoffer being buried under giant stadium
is a popular example but perhaps none is
more pervasive than arnold rothstein
fixing the 1919 baseball world series
just to be clear we're not saying that
he did or did not do it neither side has
ever been proven conclusively we're
simply presenting the story as it has
been told for over a hundred years it
was october 1919 and the american league
champion chicago white sox were due to
meet the national league champion
cincinnati reds in a best of nine series
to determine the winners of the world
series ultimately the reds t153 but
rumors started flying around that the
games had not been on the up and up was
it possible that some of the chicago
players intentionally threw the game and
was it possible that they were paid to
do so by arnold rothstein who made a
killing by betting against the favorites
let's examine the story bit by bit first
off why would the chicago players throw
the series well athletes back then had
only a teeny tiny fraction of the wealth
and power that they have today the owner
of the chicago white sox charles kamiski
was known as a particularly parsimonious
miser who paid his players peanuts one
of his star athletes schuler's joe
jackson who was still ranked as one of
the greatest hitters in the history of
the game only made six thousand dollars
a year which is around 85 000 today
meanwhile many other players made just
three thousand dollars which today would
be below the national salary average in
other words it was a far far cry from
the multiple hundred million dollar
contracts of today then there was also
the dreaded reserve clause back then
there was no free agency so players
couldn't move on to greener pastures
when their contracts expired their team
still retained the rights to them
essentially in perpetuity and they could
only move to another team if they
received an unconditional release from
their previous team all of this was done
to explicitly keep the players salaries
low since freedom of movement would have
increased demand and therefore granted
players leverage to ask for higher wages
honestly the way things were it's kind
of surprising that more baseball players
didn't just say screw it and throw the
game for one big payday but it did
happen on this occasion eight white sox
players were implicated in the scandal
including the aforementioned shoeless
joe jackson they were indicted on
conspiracy to defraud charges and
brought before a grand jury ultimately
the black socks as they were dubbed by
the media were all found not guilty but
they were still banned for life from
professional baseball so where does
arnold rothstein come in allegedly he
was the shadowy figure behind the scenes
who bankrolled the entire operation two
gamblers came to him with the idea both
of them having connections to the white
sox one was joseph sport sullivan and
the other was william sleepy bill burns
rothstein went with sullivan since he
had a better reputation and paid him
between 80 000 to 100 000 to arrange the
whole thing but as we know there is no
honor among thieves and it was alleged
during the trial that sullivan only
turned over fifteen thousand dollars to
the players and kept the rest somewhere
definitely got screwed over in this deal
but it certainly wasn't arnold rothstone
rumors say that he placed several bets
on the cincinnati reds totaling almost
270 thousand dollars and that he walked
away with a princely sum out of the
whole ordeal however he was called to
testify before the grand jury in october
1920 but he couldn't be tied to anything
so rothstein was cleared of any
involvement and strangely enough some
historians agree with this assessment
and think that rothstein was truthful
when he said that he had no part in the
fix he was certainly aware of it you
couldn't plan a scam this big back then
without word reaching arnold rothstein
he also knew that other people used his
name while organizing the whole thing to
make it seem like a big time deal but he
chose to keep his mouth shut and stay
away from the whole matter quietly
making his own bets it was just the way
rothstein liked it all of the wins
with none of the risks
the thing is that as notorious as the
black sox betting scandal was it wasn't
even close to rothstein's biggest payday
just in 1921 alone he made two bets that
earned him five hundred thousand dollars
in eight hundred and fifty thousand
dollars respectively horse racing was
his sport of choice and he even owned a
few horses including two champion racers
named sidereel and sporting blood who
both won him those two huge bets and the
truth is that these kind of massive
gambling wins weren't even rothstein's
main moneymaker anymore because in 1920
something new came along that turned
arnold rothstein into one of the richest
gangsters in the country
prohibition january the 17th 1920 was
described as the greatest day for
organized crime in america because that
is when prohibition came into effect and
rothstein was the kind of guy who
immediately spotted the huge profits to
be made just waiting for the right man
with the right vision to come along and
he was that man so he started repairing
even before the volstead act as it was
also known came into effect therefore
when prohibition arrived rothstein was
ready he had the connections he had the
delivery network and he had that sweet
sweet nectar of the gods to keep america
tipsy and happy because he was one of
the first criminals to get in on the
action arnold rothstein became one of
the biggest bootleggers of the early
1920s as the years passed he got
outmatched by guys like al capone and
george remus but by then rothstein had
already reaped his riches not to mention
that he expanded into the heroin and
cocaine trade so he was still doing all
right for himself the 1920s represented
the peak of arnold rosstein's power
influence and wealth but they ended with
a sudden and permanent drop if you know
what we mean on november 4th 1928
rothstein was shot while attending a
meeting inside the park central hotel he
was found by the service entrance trying
to hail a cab to go to a doctor he was
taken to the hospital where doctors
pulled a 38-caliber bullet out of
rothstein's abdomen which appears to an
artery and caused a lot of bleeding
initially it was thought that he might
survive but the kingpin died of his
injuries two days later on november 6th
aged 46 during his day in hospital he
regained consciousness but stuck to the
precious code of silence until his last
breath refusing to tell the cops
anything other than his age and address
now again we'll dip into the bag of
mafia law for the reason for rothstein's
murder since nobody was ever convicted
of the crime the whole thing supposedly
happened over an unpaid gambling debt
weeks earlier rothstein attended a card
game hosted by a guy named george
mcmanus this was where arnold was
matched up against two other big time
gamblers called alvin titanic thompson
and nate raymond rothstein was
uncharacteristically unlucky that day
and he left the table owing over three
hundred thousand dollars everyone
expected him to make good on the payment
but days turned to weeks and still no
word from arnold as it turned out he
became convinced that the game had been
fixed and had no intention of paying
this put mcmanus in a delicate position
since he hosted the game and therefore
vouched for everyone at the table he
demanded a private meeting with rostein
at the park central hotel where we
presume a lot of accusations and insults
started flying around and arnold
rothstein left the room with a hole in
his gut as we said nobody was convicted
so his murder remains officially
unsolved and the funny thing is that the
money would have meant nothing to
rothstein just days after his death bet
of his came up and it would have earned
him over half a million dollars his debt
was just a tiny drop in the bucket to
him but it was the idea that he had been
conned that he couldn't stand he died
letting the world know that arnold
rothstein was nobody's sucker so i
really hope you enjoyed today's video if
you'd like to check out another video
that we've done about gangsters one
mentioned in today's video please do
check out our bugsy seagull video which
i'll link to on the screen now and thank
you for watching thanks again to war
thunder for sponsoring today's video
remember to follow the link in the
description below to start playing their
free vehicle combat game with three free
days of premium play and a premium
vehicle as well go check it out thank
you for watching